One of the things we don't understand
very well from a political perspective
is that conservatives and liberals are
actually quite different people,
temperamentally,
and so the way they filter the world is
different and so the world presents
itself as a set of facts that are
different for liberals and conservatives
and so it's not just a matter of
opinion.
It's a matter of fundamental,
fundamental,
temperamental orientation and to
understand that other people,
this is the diversity argument.
If you were really making a diversity
argument that was real,
this is the argument you would make.
People are actually different and and
you need to understand the differences
because there's advantages and
disadvantages to all of the differences
and there's also advantages and
disadvantages into how we interact with
each other.
That's important.
People to know.
It's really useful to talk to someone
who's different than you because they
actually see a different world and if
you listen to them,
they can give you some insight into that
world and that means that your world can
expand and maybe if you knew that they
were actually different,
like biologically different,
you'd be more inclined to listen to them
because you wouldn't think that.
I mean obviously people are arbitrary
and ignorant and malevolent at times.
That's.
Those are separate issues.
But apart from all that,
they're also very different from one
another.
And if you listen to someone who's
different from you,
they'll tell you things you don't know.
And that's really helpful.
Unless you would like to not know things
and then you run like,
you know,
face first into walls.